did we not learn during covid and all
the stimulus and the free money that
that may be printing money and free
money isn't the best solution for people
like using Ubi as an example uh allow me
to comment on that yes sir feel free
okay
what you're not considering
is
okay
um so we have this inflation all right
this past year is eight percent or
whatever it'd probably be lower this
year but still eight percent well yeah
we were printing money and so that there
was some inevitability to that so people
who don't like the politics of that
argue against that and saying you
shouldn't have printed money
what was the [ __ ] alternative
you don't have money and you get kicked
out of your home and you don't have a
job
ask yourself suppose we didn't do that
and the entire industry that required
people to leave their homes and pay
money at a restaurant at a shopping mall
at every place that required people's
presence they would be out of a job and
homeless oh let's do that because that's
a better solution than having a little
bit of inflation two years after you
have a stimulus package
people don't do enough thinking about
what other consequences would have taken
place
had decisions been different
it's not just simply don't do the
package that way we won't have a little
bit of inflation a few years later
that's not really the metric that's
going on at that time
think it through now if you can say I'd
rather not have the inflation and I
don't mind millions of people kicked out
of their residence homeless with no job
then that's a decision as long as it's
an informed decision you can prefer that
it's a free country you can prefer that
and vote that way
for me we have the power to print the
money keeping people in a job
through the crisis
I think that was one of the wisest
decisions uh economic decisions that
could have been made at the time I guess
that's my opinion no and that's
perfectly fine when you say think it
through who would disagree with that you
know how like they do like in South
Korea they with the help of U.S forces
they do war games okay well if China
does this and we're going to do this and
they do a thousand different uh military
yeah these war games all these things
that happen and then different all the
time different methodologies different
why don't they do stuff like that with
like covet it's like okay cool if we're
gonna lock down the world and we can't
have money we don't have jobs and
everyone's losing their jobs all right
we're gonna print money like why doesn't
the government do something like that in
terms of like war games so like the next
time covet happens because it'll
probably happen the problem you don't
have to print all this money it was a
once in a century we hope knock on wood
well
statistically it was once in a century
the previous one was a Black Swan event
the previous one was 100 years earlier
and so uh we went a century without a
pandemic so I don't know that Solutions
we put into place today would be the
solutions we would choose a hundred
years from now in the next pandemic uh
so so yes uh the scenarios are good to
explore yes you can ask how much money
was pulled out of the stock market
um when Society closed down that was
that V uh drop that we took yeah and by
the way uh the market went back up
within 18 months it was higher than it
was the day before it dropped six months
yeah was it that quick I forgot it was
even that quick thank you the V recovery
they call it so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]